F: Salut les Mentalos,
aujourd'hui je suis pas tout seul
et non tu l'as vu il y a quelqu'un à côté de moi c'est Monsieur Clément Bonpoil
Aaaahhh mais c'est qui?
C: Salut !
F: Anecdote marrante dans la vidéo que j'avais faite sur Pi celle ci
sur le deuxième je parlais d'un mec, qui s'appelle Clément Bonpoil
qu'il avait un record sur lequel il avait récité très... le plus rapidement possible 300 décimales..
C: 600 décimales c'est ça
F: Hein?
C: 600 décimales
F: 600 décimales de Pi, tu vois déjà je te casse en 2.
C: Pas grave
*rires*
F: Alors le truc marrant c'est que en parallèle de la sortie de cette vidéo Clément,
il m'a contacté sur Facebook
Mais il savait pas que je parlerais de lui et que c'était prévu.
et moi je ne savais pas qu'il allait me contacter
et voilà. Bref
Si tu as réussi à faire ça, c'est aussi parce que tu as une capacité, tu es un peu un X-Men
C: un X-Men de ligue 2 CFA, oui si tu veux *rires*
F: Tu es... on dit synesthète c'est ça?
C: c'est sa synestéte ouai
F: Tu es synesthète
et je vous avais parlé une fois très rapidement de la synesthésie, en disant qu'il y avait 152 formes de synesthésie
en tout cas de détectées aujourd'hui. Et bien, c'est un synesthète, et c'est-à-dire que concrètement, c'est quoi la synesthésie?
C : La synesthésie c'est que l'on va mélanger différents sens, ça va se faire automatiquement, les sens vont se mélanger.
Par exemple on va voir des chiffres en couleur, des choses comme ça.
Et du coup il y a plusieurs formes de synesthésie. Pour moi la synesthésie au niveau des couleurs, c'est voir la vie en rose,
ça permet de rire jaune, de pas avoir des idées noires, et d'éviter les pages blanches. Je pense que je vais y aller après cette phrase!
F : Aller, salut!
F : Non mais tu avais écris un texte comme ça sur Facebook qui était super bien
D'ailleurs je mets le lien Facebook de Clément Bonpoil directement dans la description si vous voulez le voir.
J'avais bien aimé ce texte là. En fait c'est hyper intéressant parce que toi tu fais spontanément,
sans aucune maîtrise d'ailleurs de ça, des choses que nous on essaye de rationaliser
quand je vous parle de mémoire, de vous faire des images, de mettre des couleurs, etc, d'associer d'autres sens,
toi c'est des connexions qu'il y a directement dans ta tête.
C : C'est ça, qui ne sont pas maîtrisées du tout.
F : Et oui, c'est dingue!
Est-ce que du coup ça se traduit aussi par des émotions, est-ce qu'il y a des choses que tu aimes ou pas,
et des choses qui sont pourtant immatérielles ou pas concrètes? Genre des chiffres, des trucs comme ça?
C : Il y a des choses immatérielles, par exemple je vais avoir le nombre 36 qui va être stressant
C : C'est vraiment ça hein. La vidéo la plus flippante du monde.
F : Le mec te dit normalement : 36 ça me... tu vois, à un moment donné!
C : Et après tu vois, au niveau des jours par exemple, le mardi va être vert, le mercredi orange, des choses comme ça
et par exemple tous les mardis de l'année 2001, donc le mardi 9 janvier 2001,
le 20 février ou le 25 septembre donc, ça va avoir un goût de menthe after eight.
Alors pourquoi ? parce que j'en ai mangé une fois j'ai pas aimé un jour de cette année là
C'est associé au mardi
parce que c'est vert et que j'ai ce gout là en bouche
quand j'y pense.
f : Et le vert c'est des trucs que tu n'aimes pas du coup?
Le vert c'est plus les trucs que j'aime pas en général
F : du coup on n'aime pas trop le mardi quoi ...
On n'aime pas trop le mardi, je me lève pas le mardi faut le savoir
Genre le 36 octobre là en plus ça va être *geste de la main*
T'imagines, nous on fait des efforts de mnémotechnies pour vraiment exploiter toute notre mémoire
Ce qui est vraiment impressionnant surtout c'est d'avoir des techniques, moi c'est ce qui m'impressionne.
On est toujours impressionné par ce qu'on n'est pas. Moi je suis hyper impressionné par toi.
Faut pas !
Excusez-moi on va se pécho avant la fin de la vidéo !!
Surtout que c'est moins de 18 (ans) quand ça va passer !
Dès que je m'approche de lui il va penser à 36, tu vois ça me stresse et tout !
Et tout à l'heure on parlait, parce qu'il écrit des textes aussi
tu écris des chansons, tu as mis des choses sur youtube qui sont vachement cool
Je vous mettrai ça aussi
On parlait de la manière que tu avais d'écrire des rimes
ET ça je trouve que ça traduis exactement ce qui se passe dans ta tête
Des fois il ne va pas faire rimer comme nous on l'entend 2 mots entre eux
Il va les faire rimer au niveau de la couleur que ça lui renvoie mentalement
C'est ça que tu m'expliquais ? C'est ça !
Des mots que je vais écrire qui vont me rappeler soit une couleur, soit une sensation
Et directement il va y avoir un autre mot qui va être rattaché à ça
Et du coup ce mot là je vais le décomposer en plusieurs sens
et une rime qui va naitre à partir de ça
C'est incroyable !
Qui rime qui est bien ou pas d'ailleurs !
Mais ça fait une rime ou il y a un truc qui se construit, une histoire du coup
Est-ce qu'on a une explication scientifique de la synesthésie ou pas ?
Alors il y a beaucoup d'ouvrages là dessus
On peut trouver plein de choses sur internet sur ça
Il y a le facteur génétique qui rentre en compte parfois
Il y a des chocs à la tête etc...
J'ai dit dans une chanson que j'étais parti trop près du mur s'il faut, ça a peut être joué !
Mais sinon il y a pas mal d'explications qui sont données ou non
C'est comme ce que tu fais pour deviner ce qui se passe dans la tête des gens
Ouais mais moi je vois la procédure, la méthode, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Comment ça se fait que c'est connecté comme ça ?
Non mais il y a encore tellement de choses qu'on ne sait pas de toutes les manières, c'est ça qui est fascinant
Est-ce que ça t'a créé des handicaps sur certaines choses ou pas ?
Par exemple dans mon répertoire je n'ai aucun numéro de téléphone
J'ai que les numéros je n'ai pas de noms
Parce que je vois à qui ça correspond
Forcément parfois tu as des numéros que tu voudrais oublier mais ça reste dans ta tête pendant 10 ans
ah oui un petit peu comme les hypermnésiques
s'il y a une partie qui est dure à oublier
puisque ça te créé un souvenir, c'est un souvenir impérissable
De toute façon je pense que dès qu'il y a de l'émotion par rapport à quelque chose ça marque, mais pour tout le monde
oui oui bien sur
MAis du coup avec la synesthésie c'est décuplé
Après tu sais qu'il y a des exercices pour symboliser l'oubli
Par exemple tu peux écrire quelque chose que tu veux oublier sur un papier et le bruler
d'accord
C'est un geste symbolique mais ça aide l'inconscient à travailler là dessus
J'ai quand même une question par rapport au record que tu as eu, par rapport à Pi
Pour bien préciser, le record c'est d'avoir récité les 600 premières décimales de pi le plus rapidement possible
C'est à dire en 3 minutes je crois ?
2 minutes 08
Oh 2minutes 08 s'il te plait !!
A l'aise
Et alors du coup comment ça se passe ?
Est-ce que tu décris quelque chose mentalement
Ou est-ce que ca te vient comme ça *bam bam bam*
Bah tu vois quand là j'y pense ça fait :
1415926535 897932
Et en fait ça fait un chemin.
Genre je vois un arbre pour le 1
Je vais avoir une sensation qui va arriver
Entre la 10è décimale et la 20è je sais que mon oreille droite va être impactée
En fait je ne peux pas expliquer
Par contre je ne peux pas les refaire à l'écrit
Je l'ai testé une fois en soirée d'ailleurs
à l'écrire, ça ne marche pas
il faut que ça aille vite, je ne peux pas les écrire lentement
ta main ne va pas assez vite par rapport à ta pensée
C'est OUF !
Et au niveau de l'apprentissage ça c'est passé comment ?
Tu les as lu plusieurs fois et ça s'est imprégné ? Ou ...
C'set ça, c'est une imprégnation. J'ai vraiment lu et j'ai pas cherché
Au début ça m'est venu
J'étais en stage de fin d'étude
Je bloque un créneau à un manager
et l'horaire c'est 14h15
Donc 1-4-1-5
Là j'ai les chiffres qui me viens 9-2
"Merde d'où ça vient ?"
ah c'est drôle !
Je crois qu'il y a eu 16h mais voilà quand même ...
Et donc du coup je me suis dit "ok c'est les premières décimales", et j'ai voulu voir jusqu'ou ça pouvait aller du coup
je sais pas j'avais lu
je pense en avoir entre 600 et 1000
et au final c'était 600
F : Tu l'as lu "La vie en bleu" de Daniel Tammet ?
"Je suis né un jour bleu" (ah oui), je suis en train de le lire
C'est marrant parce que eux ils voient les mercredi en bleu
Lui il a un don qui est phénoménal
On a notre Daniel Tammet à nous, c'est Clément !
Et là on s'est fait tacler !
Si Daniel Tammet était du top 14 ..ah bah je vais me faire tacler parcequ'il y a des mecs du rugby qui vont regardeR..!
bon bah je vais rien dire, cette fois c'est bon!
Petit bonus on allait arrêter la vidéo, et Clément me demande si on ne peut pas faire un petit truc de mentalisme ?
En fait je n'ai jamais fait de mensonge, de vérité ou de visualisation sur un synesthète
donc je ne sais pas du tout ce que ça va rendre
j'aimerais ... alors je ne vais pas trop trop te regarder
pour l'instant
j'aimerais que dans ta tête, sans donner de signe physique
que tu imagines une pièce que tu mets soit dans ta main droite, soit dans ta main gauche, soit dans ta poche
tu me dis quand c'est fait. C'est bon. Ok
Je vais te poser 2 questions. Prend toujours un temps de réponse parceque si tu dis la vérité,
il ne faut pas que ça vienne trop vite
parce que le mensonge serait écarté ça me donnerait un indice
donc tu compte jusqu'à 1dans ta tête
quoi qu'il arrive, que tu dises un mensonge ou la vérité
Première question : est-ce que la pièce est dans tes mains ?
euh non
ok.Maintenant le petit truc dont je te parlais c'est un déplacement mental
et sur un synesthète je ne sais pas ce que ça va rendre
Si la pièce est dans ta main droite tu vas la mettre dans ta poche
Si elle était dans ta poche tu l'as met dans ta main gauche
et si elle était dans ta main gauche tu l'as laisse ici pour m'embrouiller
Je te laisse faire si besoin est un déplacement mental pour rien et tu me dis quand tu es prêt
c'est bon.
Maintenant question rafale : tu réponds le plus vite possible
Soit la vérité, soit un mensonge c'est toi qui décide
est-ce que la pièce est dans tes mains. Oui
Est-ce que la pièce est dans ta chaussure ? Non
ESt-ce que tu as bien mangé ce matin?oui
37 ça te fais quoi comme émotion ?
C'est.... de l'acier un petit peu c'est bizarre
ok.Superman c'est un 37?
Non ! Superman c'est du lundi donc c'est rouge
est-ce que la pièce est dans ta main droite? oui
ok je pense savoir où elle est.
Main gauche !?
C'est ça ! C'est correct ouiiii!
C'est bon !
ET moi j'ai appris que superman c'était un petit peu le lundi parce que faut peut-être pas déconner !
Du coup, franchement sur ce passage là il y a 2 mecs chelou en même temps!
il n'y en a pas un qui est moins chelou que l'autre
ça va ça t'a plu ? Ouais c'est énorme !
Je me suis dit "non il va se planter" et pas du tout!
ah ça va ça a été c'était cool!
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, on va couper là parce que ça doit déjà être un petit peu long
Merci à vous, merci mon pote
J'espère qu'on va garder le contact ensemble
Si la vidéo vous a plu vous pouvez nous le faire savoir et soutenir la chaine en mettant un petit pouce en l'air !
N'hésitez pas également à vous abonner avant de partir
Parce que le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour du 1 janvier au 31 décembre donc rdv demain à 17h ciao !